[Música]
imagínate que estás parado en una playa
mirando al océano rompen las olas y el
azul se extiende hasta el infinito
asimila el alcance y la magnitud de todo
esto ahora pregúntate de qué tamaño es
cuan grande es el océano primero hay que
entender que en realidad es solo un
océano compuesto por cinco cuencas
llamadas pacífico atlántico e índico
ártico y antártico
si bien estas cuencas se conocen como
océanos en realidad son parte de una
única y enorme masa de agua un océano
que define la propia cara del planeta
tierra cubre cerca del 71 por ciento de
la superficie del planeta unos 360
millones de kilómetros cuadrados más de
36 veces el área de eeuu es una
extensión tan vasta que he visto desde
el espacio es con creces la
característica principal del planeta
hablando de espacio el océano tiene más
de uno
coma tres mil millones de kilómetros
cúbicos de agua es decir suficiente como
para sumergir a eeuu bajo una masa de
agua salada de más de 132 kilómetros de
alto muy por encima de las nubes más
altas y que se extiende hacia lo
profundo de la atmósfera superior el
océano representa el 97 por ciento del
contenido total de agua en tierra además
el océano contiene más del 99 por ciento
de la biosfera del mundo o sea los
espacios y lugares en los que existe
vida contempla eso por un momento el
mundo inmediato tal como lo conocemos la
totalidad de todo el espacio comprendido
por los propios continentes
todo eso representa sólo el 1% de la
biosfera el 1% el océano es todo lo
demás es físicamente enorme su
importancia para la vida es casi
inigualable contiene también las mayores
características geológicas
del planeta aquí están cuatro de las más
notables el océano tiene la cadena
montañosa más grande del mundo la dorsal
oceánica esta cordillera subacuática
mide 65.000 kilómetros 10 veces más
larga que la cadena montañosa más larga
de tierra firme los andes bajo el
estrecho de dinamarca está la catarata
más grande del mundo por esta catarata
enorme caen más o menos 116 veces más de
agua por segundo que por las cataratas
inga del río congo la cascada con más
volumen en tierra firme la montaña más
alta del mundo se encuentra en el océano
oculta a plena vista el mauna kea de
hawai tiene 4200 metros sobre el nivel
del mar y sus laderas se desploman bajo
las olas otros 5 mil 800 metros desde su
cima nevada hasta el fondo
esta montaña hawaiana mide unos 10.000
metros y supera a la minúscula cima del
everest en más de un kilómetro y el
cañón más profundo del mundo la fosa del
challenger a 11 km bajo la superficie
del océano es unas seis veces más
profundo que el gran cañón eso es
suficiente para sumergir al monte
everest y que quedan más de mil 2.1
kilómetros de agua por encima de su pico
visto de otra manera la profundidad de
la fosa de challenger es más o menos
igual a la altura a la que vuelan los
aviones comerciales entonces desde
cualquier punto de vista el océano es
inmenso realmente
te define al planeta tiene las más
grandes características geológicas forma
el mayor espacio vital y por lo tanto en
él habitan la mayor variedad de vida en
la tierra su alcance es prácticamente
incomprensible pero no es tan grande ni
tan vasto ni tan extraordinario como
para ser intocable con cerca del 50 por
ciento de la población mundial viviendo
a 100 kilómetros de la costa y la mayor
parte del resto cerca de lagos ríos o
pantanos que en última instancia
desembocan en el mar prácticamente cada
persona del planeta tiene la oportunidad
de influir en la salud general de los
océanos del mundo vemos la influencia
humana en todo el océano sin importar la
profundidad ni la distancia el océano
define nuestro planeta pero también
nosotros definimos el océano